[Music]
welcome to another episode of the adi
hour our 20th episode which i'm very
grateful about uh we've been doing this
since about february this year so it's
really been nice to see this come to
fruition in a lot of ways today i'm
honored to be able to host another
conversation on a really important topic
we're going to be talking about
depression ketamine and just important
considerations about navigating the
mental health care system so as usual on
this podcast you know some really
important some heavy topics but it's
also going to be encouraging i think as
well just as we talk through um some of
these experiences from our two guests
both from a provider's standpoint um and
from someone who's walked through the
system and they're actually working
together as colleagues in this
moment as well so i'll let them
elaborate on that as we go through but
i'm honored to be able to to welcome two
guests to the podcast today the first of
which is dr jerry santacora
dr santa cora is the gross professor of
psychiatry at the yale school of
medicine he's also the director of the
yale depression research program and the
co-director of the interventional
psychiatry program at yale new haven
hospital
he's someone who's been engaged in
research for over 25 years using both
preclinical rolex models and also human
clinical studies to really understand
the biology of neuropsychiatric
illnesses and also to really think about
and develop new approaches for treating
and preventing those illnesses in the
first place
he's someone who's led a lot of
different projects projects within the
national institutes of health projects
have been sponsored by foundations
projects have been sponsored within
industry so it has a lot of experiences
in different realms
and what is really impressive is that
he's also worked on creating and
disseminating educational resources and
also providing leadership to both
national and international consensus
on international consensus statements
he's won numerous awards for his work
he's a fellow of the american college of
neuropsychopharmacology
he also received the anna mankia
stiftung international award and
received a joel echols research award so
i'm grateful for the work that he does
in the space and honored to welcome dr
jerry center court to the addie hour
podcast
thank you nick it's really a pleasure to
be here thanks so much for being here
my second guest is ashley clayton
and ashley is someone who describes
herself as a person who loves stories is
an avid reader of poetry memoirs and
non-fiction
she also finds joy and comfort in music
and impressively during the pandemic has
picked up and has been teaching herself
the banjo
ashley is someone who grew up in the
rolling hills of kentucky moved to
connecticut for grad school and has been
living in connecticut for the past 12
years
she has a master's degree in community
psychology and is also a research
associate in the department of
psychiatry at the yale school of
medicine she initially ventured into the
community psychology space through her
determination to use her first-hand
experience with mental illness for the
greater good and she's also very
dedicated to social justice
so she's a mental health advocate or
activist rather she's also published
numerous research papers on social
inclusion of individuals living with
severe mental illness on maternal mental
health on recovery-oriented and
person-centered care and has also
written healthcare narratives and essays
she's on the advisory board of different
organizations also owns a consulting
business where she provides consultation
in program evaluation and patient
engagement so i'm deeply grateful for
all the important work that she does and
also thankful that she's taking time to
join us here on the adr podcast
yeah thank you so much for having me i'm
looking forward to our conversation
definitely definitely looking forward to
it and grateful to both of you this in
some senses is in some sense as an
in-house conversation since we're all at
yale but also we want to make sure as we
always do on this podcast that we're
just communicating to the general public
as well and so i'm grateful for the ways
you all have done that already and i
know this conversation is going to
continue to do that as well
but as i always do on the podcast i
always like to check in and see how
people are doing overall you know
especially as we wrap up 2020 as we look
forward to 2021 um and ashley why don't
we go ahead and start with you and just
see how you're doing in this moment
yeah um i think the most honest answer
to that is i am both okay and very much
not okay
um so i think you know the last we're
coming into this you know two years of a
pandemic um
you know uh and i think we're all
sharing that stress um i you know
there's a low low level or sometimes a
high level of just general overwhelmed
stress fatigue so definitely um you know
feeling that i think
um my life during the pandemic
personally has been um challenging aside
from
you know kind of everything we're all
experiencing together
the day that connecticut um shut down my
brother
uh they found a second tumor he and his
glioblastoma so kind of at the exact
moment that everything
you know happened
our world my my family life you know got
got pretty chaotic and so he died
earlier
this year and that's been you know very
painful
and
and sad so i've been in also you know a
process of mourning and grieving but
also being away from my family not being
there as much as i want to be um so
um you know in 2020 i had three job
transitions which um you know is is
stressful um
i've had some pretty
strange um health issues physical health
issues so dealing with those but
also
i also feel okay
in some weird ways so i you know i think
the most honest answer is really i'm
okay and not okay and i think a lot of
people can relate yeah
yeah i think that's such an important
piece to just get across i mean just the
level of candor that you just shared as
well with everything that you've gone
through in the last two years and the
fact that you can have both of those
simultaneously being okay and now okay i
think a lot of ways and people have
heard this on this program before but
that's validating i think for a lot of
people to hear because sometimes i think
people feel stuck in one or the other
like either i have to not be doing well
or i can like there's no
people don't always have room to have
both and i think that's really important
acknowledge that you're sharing that so
really appreciate that
jerry what about you how are you doing
in this moment
ashley captured it extremely uh
concisely very well in many ways and
it's been a difficult
professionally it's been a hard year as
you can imagine it's been extremely busy
and trying to adapt to working in
environments that were not
prepared to work in doing so much by
telemedicine and a lot of the treatments
we give are actually hands-on and trying
to figure out how to do that
when the volumes are so high but yet
all the procedures that we need to
ensure safety become
so much more time consuming it's been a
struggle but
overall i have to consider myself one of
the real lucky people that
has
not been directly personally affected by
this pandemic and that
has been extremely fortunate and
you know it
the burden has not been shared evenly
from everybody that's you
yeah that's very true as well and again
you know similar to ashley i just
appreciate the way you shared that
honestly because i think sometimes as
well and that's also come up that people
who haven't been directly affected
sometimes lessen the challenges they've
also faced so i mean for you as a as a
provider obviously that's also very
challenging but at the same time as you
mentioned you do have a place of
thankfulness being blessed and
privileged to not have been directly
affected so i appreciate you putting
that
in context as well and again you know
even as we're starting that's one of the
reasons why i was so um grateful that
both of you have joined just the level
of candor with which you both speak and
the honesty and the realness i think
goes a very very long way
another question what you want to ask i
may allude to this in the introduction
but you all have had a shift in your
relationship over the years but i also
just wanted to start and ask how the two
of you met in what context and how
that relationship has changed and
developed over the years so whoever
wants to know the best best person to
ask to introduce that but i'll let you
all
decide i suppose
sure is it okay if i go oh yeah
definitely please do
so um i met jerry in
the early
part of 2016. so um i was hanging out
with a colleague a mutual colleague but
we're all colleagues so of ours
and i had really at this point been
struggling really severely with
depression for the last few years but
the first time i was actually having
what we call like functional impairments
um you know i was having some cognitive
deficits struggling at work i mean i
would just like look at my spreadsheet
and be like i don't i
i don't know what to do
um
and so i actually was on a partial
medical leap from work which was the
first time i ever needed to do that and
so i reached out to a colleague who um
does some research
um with ketamine in a different area
than depression and just said hey i
remember you saying something about
ketamine and depression could you could
you meet and talk and so he actually
referred me to jerry who at the time was
running
a phase two clinical trial um and so
uh he he made a call on my behalf later
that week you know i met with jerry to
really talk about
what his his research projects and to
see you know am i a good candidate for
any of the studies he has going on and
is it something that if i am i would
want to move forward with and so that's
really um you know how we how we met
first and uh you know kind of a
principal investigator physician
uh patient
research you know research participant
relationship and i did end up
participating in some clinical trials
and
throughout that year and um you know he
was involved
after the the studies ended and the
transition of my care kind of over to um
to a team i have now um
but i would you know in the last few
years you know we've we've really
established our relationship as
colleagues as people who really want to
talk publicly and have to have good
conversations about what is it like to
um you know live with
severe depression what treatments are
available
um all of these different things
together that's a path i think we really
wanted to do so we've kind of um
separated our
doctor-patient relationship really and
have established a firm relationship as
colleagues here um in the university so
yeah i i i look at from the perspective
there are many good doctors that could
do what i was doing to help ashley but
there are very few people like ashley
that could really help us
understand better header provide the
best care we can to patients and i think
i think
our collaboration through this sense is
is
real important and and i know you
you do have good care elsewhere so that
yeah there are more good doctors than
there are people like you so
thank you wow wow that's really powerful
i think in a lot of ways and
just to be able to have i mean i'm
speculating here but i'd say that kind
of relationship is rare
to have that collegial relationship and
then people who are mutually invested um
and willing to learn from each
perspective as well and i think that
goes we'll get into this as well that
probably goes a long way into helping
both sides see blind spots that we might
not have seen otherwise which i think is
really important i did want to pick up
actually on one um aspect that you
mentioned too in terms of you know
walking through severe depression
because i think
that's a conversation that's really
important um that has talked about when
society's come up in this
uh this podcast as well but i think
sometimes
from a general perspective there's a
lack of clarity on what people mean when
they say okay i'm feeling depressed
versus clinical depression versus severe
depression and so how as you both have
talked about this in public science how
do you usually help people
understand what those phrases mean and
what the distinctions are
actually i guess we can start with you
and then let me go to jerry from there
sure yeah um so i think um
there is a conflation of poverty of um
depression and sadness that they are one
and the same that when i'm feeling sad
or down about something that i'm
depressed we use that term
you know very flippantly and often
um
and
that is not true
i think
i also think clinical depression can
look really different for different
people
um because you can have what i like to
call like a constellation of symptoms
and so
someone's clinical depression even if
we're categorizing as clinical
depression can look really different
than someone else's
um so i think it's important to
talk about and i'll just speak mostly to
my experience and i'll let jerry do all
the
um you know from a clinical perspective
these are kind of the lines that we draw
or what we mean or what is meaningful
um but i re i often refer to what i am
living with is severe depression or um
um you know really difficult to treat
depression um
and
i think
for me if you think about like
depression as a spectrum and you have
this like
you know oh like things aren't feeling
right i'm feeling down i'm feeling
fatigued maybe i'm not sleeping i'm
feeling restless you know and there's a
whole spectrum of where that goes to
like where i feel like
my depression when it's not treated or
well managed goes real real fast
um which is this like
overwhelming fatigue that my my bones
feel like they are
hollow but made of iron like there's
like nothing in them there's a it's an
empty feeling but it's a heavy feeling
um you know i often feel like there's
just like someone sitting on my chest
and it's i have to work to breathe not
in the same way like if i'm panicked and
i'm struggling to breathe but if just
like it feels laborsome
um there's also i you know tend to have
like a loss of affect of like you know
i'm a person i feel things really deeply
i'm a deep thinker and introspective
and like
i will know all these things
intellectually but i will look at my
husband and i might not have any
feelings toward him and that's really
painful
to you know to experience
and i think for me in particular and one
thing i probably don't do a good enough
job of saying because to me
they go together so well but it's not
true is
my depression is often accompanied by
pretty intense suicidal ideation and
that's not that's not true for everyone
even people who have severe depression
might not have
um suicidal ideation
but mine tend to be
pretty close one and the same
and so
you know
before i you know met jerry and before i
was in the studies and
i was walking around for four years and
every single day and it got
progressively worse and by the time i
met jerry like every single minute like
all's i was thinking about is like how
much i wanted to die
and like what a burden that is to carry
um and just how how paralyzing that can
be um and i think depending on the
constellation of symptoms i i have as an
adult i didn't when i was younger have
what i refer to as kind of these
functional impairments um but
um you know i have trouble seeing the
future thinking past sometimes i can't
even think past a day sometimes i can't
even think past an hour
which makes it really hard to
problem solve and tolerate and um do
anything so i think there's there's a
range there um but for me personally my
experience that's that's kind of what i
mean when i talk about it yeah i think
that's really helpful just the way
you've painted that picture and even the
bravery and sharing that as well because
i'm you know imagining people
who've walked through that themselves
hearing someone else talk about it how
helpful and valid that could be and for
those who have friends and loved ones
who don't always know how to respond or
how to react to it just hearing that
personal perspective i think is so
helpful in terms of context i really
appreciate the way that you've
painted that and also just clarified
some of the distinctions as well because
you're right we do use it flippingly not
intentionally but it really is important
to have that distinct so people can
really understand the differences as
well
i'll go ahead and actually yeah i'm just
going to say the one thing that i think
was i also think about is
we often think of like happiness as the
opposite of depression
um and like happiness might might i'm
not convinced but might be the opposite
of sadness which is not depression but
andrew solomon said it and he was like
the opposite of depression isn't
happiness the opposite of depression is
vitality
i feel like that like i was like yes um
like those things feel
yeah
true that's really good it actually
reminds me of what you said the onset
too just that you can be okay and not
okay at the same time yeah and that that
can be
that can be a good place to be it can
also be a challenging place to be and
there's not one static
response to that but even that in itself
doesn't convey that you know a sense of
happiness all the time
which i think sometimes like you said
people are looking for but that's just
not the reality of
successfully navigating mental health in
general so i really appreciate that as
well
do you anything that you want to add
there even in terms of big pictures
ashley's painting that picture for us
yeah actually pick up on a few things
that ashley said but i think
your psychiatry in general is really
plagued by having a lexicon that
overlaps so much with
lay language and these words like
feeling depressed and sad
i get used interchangeably
where they really aren't sadness is a
symptom of depression
and we use a lot of words in psychiatry
in our common
uh
conversations that we have a different
clinical meaning when we're really being
specific about it
but i think the other
issue that ashley touched upon which is
so critical is depression is truly
you know it's what we call a
waste paper basket diagnosis meaning
it's a diagnosis of exclusion so you
have these set of symptoms
and signs
and we can't find a reason for them if
we find a reason for them you don't have
depression
you know if you have hypothyroidism you
have hypothyroidism if you're
early-stage parkinson's you have
parkinson's you don't so depression by
definition is something we don't really
can't really identify we don't have a
positive test for depression we have
symptoms and we rule out all the other
alternatives and if we can't find
anything
we're left with the diagnosis of
depression
and and that alone as you could imagine
makes it a very hetero heterogeneous
disorder i mean there are probably many
different ways you can get to that
endpoint
of having those signs and symptoms so it
makes it very difficult then and again
following with what asha was saying it
isn't a sort of dichotomous thing where
you're depressed or not depressed in
fact
most people don't fit that
thing it's it's on a continuum of how
far
um
and not only just on a continuum it's
probably not a single axis
so it probably is not you know happy to
said in fact we know neurobiologically
it's not seeing brain regions
that control things like reward and
control things like anxiety there's
actually different brain regions that
are involved and
there's no reason to think that you know
this is on a slide rule that you you
just go from one to the other there's
probably multiple different axes
involved in the way you're feeling so
very long-winded way of saying it's
complicated and complex
i i really for me it boils down to
the functional
impact on somebody's life
and the quality of life and those two
big issues
determining whether it needs to be
treated
how it needs to be treated
is a very individualistic type you know
model to approach
yeah i definitely you know appreciate
that that context as well and especially
the functionality because i think you
know for for many of us who are mental
advocates that's something we often talk
about whether people notice a
significant change that's impairing kind
of day-to-day
functioning or dates the activities
where it's a big shift from people's
normal
kind of interactions in the world but i
was also curious you know what you
mentioned about the exclusion piece and
for either of you i'm curious do does
that ever
become a point of frustration
for patients because i can imagine
somebody saying well you're just ruling
out everything else and saying so it
must be depression and that
you know as a patient i can imagine that
would feel very frustrating in itself
too are you sure it is or what's
underlined and just kind of
a feeling of unknown well it's just this
because we can't
find anything else like how do those
conversations well i promise you as a
clinician and as a scientist it's very
frustrating too
i i think it's
you know it's humbling
and i
i approached us
by saying you know i let people know
that just because we don't know exactly
what it is doesn't mean we don't know
how to provide treatment and we don't
know how to make things better um we we
can
know that without knowing exactly what's
going on neurobiologically or or having
the perfect diagnosis
um i you know to take it to the extreme
i always remind people that you know
newton
isn't completely right in classical
physics but it's still enough where you
can build the empire state building and
have it staying for hundreds of years so
you know we can have enough of an
understanding to understand how to treat
these
but
we really don't know the underlying
neurobiology for depression is something
i know you you're working hard at our
lab is working hard at
i think we're getting closer year by
year but
we're not there yet
actually anything that you wanted to add
on that point
both either as an activist or as someone
you know
walking through and and navigating
mental illness over the years yeah yeah
so
um you know i would say
sounds terrible but you're you're lucky
if you find a doctor who's also going to
look for other things and not assume
it's depression right where there might
be the rule out if we've looked for all
these other things but i think depending
on what kind of care you have access to
and maybe even where you live in the
country and maybe who that first doctor
is that you encounter um you know they
may or may not look um
for other things
um
and you know as a as a
i i've struggled with
some form of mental illness
pretty much since i was
in middle i would say at least middle
school if not sooner i had a you know a
a pretty traumatic childhood and had a
lot of um you know symptoms of ptsd and
um
you know started self-harming when i was
very young and so
i didn't have um you know the same i
don't have the same kind of
entrance story as some people who might
become you know depressed as an adult or
might have their first you know kind of
onset or episode kind of
later of like it was pretty smack in my
face like something's
really terribly wrong and so i was
connected with care
at a pretty young age
and so
you know i would and i've been fortunate
that i've had continued access to care
that you know my parents had good health
insurance that i was able to go to good
hospitals that was in and out of
hospitals
um
and you know had a pretty good
pretty good team um for for a while
and i would say you know definitely
depression there but
they're all arbitrary lines but you know
was mostly
really kind of post traumatic stress and
and reactions to being in like some
pretty
um
not great situations
um and i've been really fortunate that
i've had a lot of therapy for that and
some time has passed where
you know that that although you know
um
is still there and still comes up and
bubbles up from time to time really
isn't something that kind of interferes
with my my daily life in a way um but
but as an adult kind of as as that
subsided i think
there was there was a process where i
think depression really kind of set in
and took over and has been the thing
that i think has has been a continuous
struggle for me for um you know the last
10 10 years um so for me it was a little
clearer
i do also have i have an autoimmune
disorder
um and
you know i think we have just discovered
that i have a primary immune deficiency
and i know you had a guest who was
talking about that i mean hopefully has
a much more severe case than i do but
um as a patient who fatigue is a
is something i really struggle with and
it's a symptom of depression and it's a
symptom of an autoimmune disorder and
then you know kind of just in the last
three months you know have have found
out oh i have these other deficiencies
that like when those are fixed maybe
i'll have some energy so i also get the
frustration of like my psychiatrist
being like it's your autoimmune disorder
and my rheumatologist being like it's
your depression and we're all just like
and i'm like i don't care about someone
please fix it um
you know
um
so i i appreciate that
that part too so yeah let me go ahead
jerry no i i yeah i do you know i just
want to make sure that that the point i
made previously in following up on what
actually saying is it's clear
i
i
i mean i think we need to be honest and
be clear that we don't know the real
underlying neurobiology but that
shouldn't be
um taken to mean that we don't know what
to do
you know and how to treat and help
people right so and it's actually saying
you know
what we call it
is actually less important than knowing
how to have treatments that are
effective and ashes right we're right on
the cusp of understanding the role that
neuroinflammation or
neuroinflammatory disease could have or
immune deficiency in these disorders and
so we don't really know the cause and
hopefully someday we can say nobody has
depression because we can identify what
it is and then treat it but
as it is we
we're pretty good about treating
the general
diagnosis as it stands today it could be
better and we're getting better but as
it is we're pretty good yeah yeah well
that's definitely definitely well taken
as well even you know not always
knowing the the reason but at least
being able to move forward in the
treatment treatment phase as well um on
that no i also want to pick up on
something that ashley mentioned this
while just in terms of you know having
providers who were
in that mindset and trying to make sure
that they they treated
the depression and you know this in a
sense is a little bit bigger than the
depression topic itself just mental
health in general as we've also talked
about on this podcast just
not only access to care but how
providers react to people from different
backgrounds and the aspects of how race
plays in racism or zip code and whether
that is uniformly
accessible across the board but even say
getting past that level saying that it
is accessible let's make that assumption
even though we know that's not true
universally but even once that is
provided actually you've talked a lot
about just navigating
the system as well and the ups and downs
that you had in that process so thinking
about your 2019 piece my struggle to
access life-saving mental health care i
was wondering if you could actually just
take us through you know as we move to
that topic how you went about putting
that piece together what was that what
was that process like for you
sure yeah of writing the article or yeah
right
motivate what motivated you to actually
put it out there yeah sure so um
you know like like i'm to get people up
to speed if you haven't read the piece
but like i said you know i met jerry i
was in some clinical trials because
unfortunately i was like one of those
people who
we didn't know really how to treat my
depression i had i had a very good
doctor and i'm um what i like to
consider a very good patient like i'm
willing to try things and if i'm not i'm
going to tell you and we'll get a better
plan um but i'm willing to hang in there
and see right um and so i mean we have
been trying for at this point two years
different
of some medicines like different classes
of medicines all sorts of things i was
running i was doing yoga i was
behaviorally doing everything i should
be doing i was in therapy i switched to
another kind of therapy and like i was
getting worse
um so by the time i you know found jerry
i think everyone was just like i don't
know what to do
um you know and i was lucky that i did
respond really well to ketamine and we
can talk about that that later which is
what i received in the clinical trial
but
um
in that process of
enrolling in a clinical trial and you
get access to this care that you can't
get otherwise right it's still being
studied and you know ketamine because
it's it is fda approved for other
reasons like you can access it unlike if
it's a you know experimental drug
without any kind of approval
um
but then the question always is like
what do you do after what you do after
the study ends what do you do after the
protocol ends protocols are different
sometimes you have continued access
sometimes it's a one and done thing
um and so you know we were in that
situation of oh my gosh i found
something i responded super well to it
i can't get access to it otherwise my
insurance is going to pay for it it's
very very expensive there are very few
people you know who at that time were
receiving it
ketamine on an off-label outpatient
basis
and
you know i ended up in the hospital um
for over a month um
on full medical leave i
you know tried
electro convulsive therapy because that
was the that is the gold standard and
that was the best option we had really
exhausted options
um you know and unfortunately i just
didn't respond to that treatment and so
after that process you know jerry and
some other physicians at yale nathan
hospital were able to get me into the
program to be able to receive ketamine
outside of a study setting um really to
save my life but it was
i mean i'll let jerry speak to it too i
mean it was a
terrible terrible struggle where
um
you know it was a
treatment by treatment approval by
whoever the administrators are and you
know love you thank you for for doing
that and saving my life but really it
was
out of
somewhat out of the doctor's control or
quite out of the doctor's control
um
and
it was particularly frustrating because
i knew there was something that worked
it wasn't like i didn't have any hope
like i knew i was like if you can get me
this like i will live
um
and
i think
being that unwell
and having to advocate for treatment and
the way right i was exhausting the tiny
resources i had left that i could have
been using to try to replenish
some some internal resources to
make the case
or connect with the right person or you
know
i mean i i feel like
i was willing to beg to be like
i will do anything because i'm going to
die
um and
it was it was terrifying um
and
i was so lucky and so i
once i got approval to receive this
treatment for free
like on that day like if it hadn't
happened that day i'd had a conversation
with one of my doctors and just said
like i don't think you guys understand
how how unwell i am and like it's gonna
be too late like if we don't fix this
like
it's it's gonna be too late and had i
walked out that day with a different
answer it certainly would have been too
late i mean that that's where i was um
and i think
you know i quickly felt well after about
a month of treatment which was such a
blessing from being so unwell but i i
knew that like
luck
played a huge role in that and that made
me very very
unsettled and scared as a person
and i also recognized like
of this situation i'm better situated
than 99.5
of people to have
negotiated this and gotten through it i
mean i'm white and well educated and
very well connected i work in the
department of psychiatry half of my
friends are psychiatrists or
psychologists
i mean i i've been in the system
for a long time so i know about the
health care system
you know i research it i mean i just was
so well equipped and i
i almost died and then
and i was like oh
this this is what happens like this is
this is how people
fall through the cracks and this is how
people die because not everyone is as
well resourced and connected as i am
and so that was what motivated it part
in part and part of it you know it was
selfish of like i was terrified it was
going to happen again
and i needed to have a better system
because i knew that like i will not get
lucky
twice
and i also knew like
i wouldn't if i had to do it again like
i wouldn't survive i still i still kind
of believe that of like
it is remarkable that i survived and i'm
so thankful for that but look if i had
to do it again i'm still not sure i
would right um and so i wrote this piece
in part for me too of like
yes to help others and build a better
system and try to think about things
differently but then also selfishly i
was like
i i almost died and i don't want that to
happen again
yeah
yeah i'm grateful that you're here
grateful that you took the time
to write that
on so many levels and but at the same
time it's so sobering
as well just to hear
how close
that was even with all the resources
that you had access to and i say that
not in the sense that you had access to
everything you needed but comparatively
as you mentioned
to others who would not have those same
resources and even still
and and well you know resources but also
like the best doctors like like the
people who are at the top of the field
cutting edge everything and then also
who are just like very good humans
um you know so it really was like the
perfect situation to be in except for
it was a whole hot mess because there's
there's no the system is very broken if
there is a system
um
yeah and jerry go ahead i was going to
just hear your you know your perspective
too and your reactions you know in those
moments and even as you and ashley have
continued to talk through this
so there is you know the aspect where
things
the system i don't even know if it's
fair to say the system is broken and i'm
not quite sure was ever put together
properly to be broken
but obviously the system
is a tremendous challenge and
especially in getting behavioral health
care or mental health care
but the positive side i actually served
this was
seeing how people
when you put them in a room
including the physicians that really
worked hard for this but the hospital
administrators you know we were very
fortunate to be at a university hospital
where hospital administrators really
worked hard to make this happen but even
the third party payers the the insurance
companies when we got to talk to the
people from there
you know
there are real people behind that that
want to help people um
so i i think
you know i i was very encouraged by the
fact that
individuals want to make the system
better
but the system
i i again i'm not even sure i can say
needs a major overhaul because i'm never
quite sure it was put together the right
way to begin with
um but clearly
the mental health system
in this country but throughout the world
is
not prepared for the need that's placed
on it right now
but it's a tremendous burden and the
cost of it is substantial
and we have to figure out a way of
delivering
all treatments more efficiently and
effectively and
or
or else we just can't afford to do this
that's it's very so so true and again
just i mean just the weight
of it and the impact and the the
sobering nature you know as you [ __ ]
but actually especially as you shared
your story and i know you shared some
suggestions in the piece as well but i'm
curious how i mean that came out in 2019
have these conversations moved and how
have you all you know both in your
individual spheres and even collectively
tried to
move things forward to i don't know the
right word if it's not
fixing the system but to
get to a place that's better because
that's i mean actually i mean it's a
matter of life and death
there's a lot of situations to be
completely frank and how
do we ensure
and move forward to more
likelihood of life
yeah so
um you know i
i'm really thankful for the relationship
i have with jerry in part because
i get to be in conversations like this
right where i get to share my story
um
both to help those who are suffering
feel
like they're not alone
and a path forward but also i think
to speak to the gravity
of the situation and i i don't think we
as a society appreciate
that um you know of how
life-threatening
depression can be and how
you know immediately urgent
and emergent it can be um and we
definitely don't fund it the way we fund
other illnesses of you know of
similar um severity or threat you know i
i was interested in this process in 2016
when i was on my first medical leave my
brother was on his medical leave after
having brain surgery from that was you
know he had cancer and we would talk
about how different our experiences were
and
um you know how both socially and who
knew that we were on leave and who
brought casseroles and those
like that whole
um thing of just like it is treated very
differently
um
but there was a point at which i'm not
at that point anymore and i'm not
comparing depression to those you're not
saying what i have is the same thing
what my brother had you know i mean
the the trajectories are less certain
there are all sorts of you know dif
major differences but like there was a
point where like my life was in
severe jeopardy if i didn't have
treatment um and so i think really
sharing bad and getting that message out
i think to put some urgency behind it of
like
one
you need access to treatment and two we
need access to better treatments because
what about those of us who
you know aren't responding to kind of
what's already there um and i think the
other thing
you know i i comment on quite a few
things in this article about you know
research and how can we make it more
beneficial to participants who sign up
and i have some suggestions for that and
i know you know the interventional
psychiatry services has taken you know
some of some of those um
suggestions um
you know but but the funding and i think
reimbursement for care and like jerry
said it's very expensive i mean i still
receive free care um which
like i have a lot of feelings about um
really complicated feelings about um you
know but definitely gratitude for sure
but lots of lots of complicated feelings
and here i am you know i told you i had
some health issues you know these last
two years and you know um one of the
medication or you know one of the
treatments i might take is going to be
like you know
ten thousand dollars a month which is
much more than my ketamine bill is but
my insurance is gonna pay for it
um kind of
without much question of like once these
things are proven and we have these labs
to say this
you can get this treatment that's very
expensive and like and have access to it
whereas like we have i don't know how
many years of data i've probably had 130
ketamine treatments and like we have
very good data that show that like when
ashley can get this treatment she is
pretty well
um
and still can't
make
that case um
so
i i don't think that necessarily even
answered a question i'm not trying to
remember what it was but
no but it's still helpful i mean there's
the context for all of it
yeah i think you know ashley highlights
many of the the
biggest problems we face but
the the issue of
providing affordable efficient and
effective behavioral health care is
is immense i mean it's it's huge and
i don't think it's possible to target it
at one spot it really is the whole
system we we need to be able to have
early recognition we need to have access
to treatment we need to have what we
call the appropriate level or step-based
care because
as we talked about depression is a very
heterogeneous unless not only
heterogeneous it's one that the evidence
is pretty clear if you can address it
early you could prevent later
progression to more severe and treatment
resistant stages
and then obviously for
the unfortunate people that don't have
early responses that we have access to
these really cutting-edge treatments and
yeah it's hard to do one of those in
isolation you know it really is
the demand is just so much greater
than the supply of the system um
it's just impossible for every person
who needs to be seen
by a behavioral health specialist to be
seen that there's just not enough
around um and especially um for
everybody to be seen by
you know fully trained psychiatrists
hopefully yeah but there's
you know there's appropriate levels of
care that can be initiated and the
earlier you can do that
the
the less expensive or less costly those
are so it's a major overhaul of the
system
that
needs to be done
um i think we're getting there and
and as i said i'm trying to infuse a
little optimism too that i think people
really care and and i think even you
know even people
think the insurance companies you know
they're just i can tell you when i talk
to the individuals that
you know
people do care it's just
how do you make this
work fiscally it's it's not an easy
solution but it's something we need to
do and i think
now more than ever we're seeing that
it's reached a crisis point
especially for psychiatric disorders
especially for depression
the impact it's having on the country
the burden on the country both
economically but even just personal
pain is
just not tolerable yeah
yeah definitely agree with you and
although you know people may feel like
we're not giving a lot of answers i
think part of it is just the awareness
too because you know for those of us and
i put myself 10 gently in that
category but in the field conversations
that we've been having for a while but
as much of these conversations need to
be expanded
and enlarged and then scope so that the
system can be changed because just in
small pockets that's not going to do it
as you were leading to as well so i
think it's really yeah i mean these are
issues that are nationwide in terms of
reimbursement in terms of how do you
bring these novel treatments
to actual clinical care i yeah i
like you i grew up my my backgrounds in
physiology and biophysics i'm a pretty
basic scientists at heart
and i always had the idea that if we
understood the basic physiology we could
develop good treatments
the rest is easy
now being in the field for
you know 25 26 years i realized that
the basic science is actually the easy
part
it's it's the implementation science
that's a lot more difficult showing that
these treatments are effective
determining who they're effective for
and then getting it even once it crosses
the goal line how do you actually get it
to patients these are these are some
real struggles yeah yeah
i think the other thing i didn't mention
i'll be mad at myself if i don't bring
up um but i've you know i've talked
about treatments and access treatments
better treatments those things that i
think the other thing that i talk about
in my article and i try to talk about
all the time and if you sit down with me
you're gonna have a long conversation
about it but it's about also the
importance of the relationship between a
doctor and the patient and how
how
in the system that we have built how
constrained
that becomes
and
you know really i think the burden that
the health care system places on doctors
is tremendous and on their time and
their reimbursement like all of these
things and in turn you know how that
impacts the relationship with the
patients and the communication
um and how
you know i i there are things that i
remember that jerry said to me while i
was in the trial that i'm like i will
forever hold that in my in my mind that
i've had other physicians who say things
i think really communicating like being
very clear to your patients especially
if they're not responding to treatments
or you're in a position where it's like
it's really hard to figure out you can
be honest about that but to really
communicate like i am not giving up on
you
and i'm in this with you
um you know and
some of some i have a team of
psychiatrists you know and some of them
i get to hear them talk because i'm at
the university and so they're out there
talking i get to
and and you know one of my physicians he
was giving a lecture and someone um
it was a mixed audience of like the
public an activist and neuroscientist
all of a sudden someone spoke up of like
what about someone who's tried 20
medications like what do you say to them
you know and he said no one has tried
everything and i will never give up on a
patient
and i mean i'm he's i believed him 100
not only because he's my doctor but like
it is like that is for sure where he's
at but like
how
much longer that can help someone
hold on
um
and just give a little more hope or like
you're holding the hope for the person
who can't hold it like that is very very
important you know and sometimes there
isn't anything to do sometimes there's
just in that moment like nothing that
can be done but i think acknowledging
and sitting down with the person and
they're suffering and really saying like
i understand what it is i'm asking you
to do
you know i understand by asking you to
stay around
what that means because i'm gonna
say i'm listening to you i'm i'm feeling
and i'm believing you rather than just
like
you know this kind of
well you know we'll get around to it
next time or um you know or i don't know
what to do and sorry um but i think
really being in it with the person
communicating that is
that is medicine
yeah that's heart in this truest form
that's so powerful and the fact that
probably our most potent medicine too
yeah yeah
very very true i'm sure you know we
could if we had more time you can talk
about the neuroscience of that and what
that's doing
to our brains and the interaction there
so i would love to sit down another time
me and go through that because yeah
that would be a great topic yeah
well i'm grateful to both of you i mean
we i feel like we talked through a lot
of important topics but then also just
touch the surface in some ways too
there's so much there so
definitely you know
be happy to revisit in some shape or
form as well but to close out i did want
to just ask both of you you know to kind
of share
what gives you hope
in this work and i know you both lose
that a little bit as well then also if
there are any resources that you want to
share with listeners actually we'll be
sure to actually put your piece on the
website too so people can access it
pretty easily thank you thank you jeremy
we'll start with you and then have
ashley wrap up
so i i do think for depression that the
advances that have been made in the past
20 years have been quite amazing that
the neurobiology
i think is decades ahead of the clinical
care
in our understanding of
some of the basic neurobiological
uh underpinnings of what we're
talking about when we talk about
depression it's not a
homogeneous illness there's many
different
pathologies or or ways that you can get
there and i think we're starting to make
real strides in understanding that
and if you think about the availability
of novel treatments i mean really up
until
the last few years
almost every medication that was
available for depression was based on
the monominergic hypothesis this very
you know hypothesis that was developed
in the early 60s um suggesting that
norepinephrine and serotonin to some
extent dopamine the basic monominergic
neurotransmitters were the core of
depression um
the neuroscience we've for for 40 years
we've known that that could not account
for the basic pathology of depression or
pathophysiology and treatment but we've
learned so much now in the past five to
ten years
novel treatments have been approved by
the fda that do not target those systems
in any way such as s ketamine or version
of ketamine for for depression and
another drug targeting the gabaergic
system for depression for postpartum
depression
many new drugs in the pipeline so we've
sort of broken out of that box that's
constrained us for nearly 50 years and
opened up a whole new vista of ways of
developing treatments but beyond that
we've also developed
novel neurostimulation treatments
tms treatments for years we've had ect
but that was it now we're really trying
to
find ways to refine those treatments
and we've also broken out of the box of
just accepting the fact that it takes
weeks to months before somebody can
benefit ashley can tell you you know one
day struggling with this it feels like
an eternity i mean when you tell
somebody well
you'll feel better but you're going to
probably feel worse before you feel
better and it may take you know two
months before it's clinically
noticeable
we've broken out of that now we know
there are treatments that can make
people feel better in a much shorter
period of time yeah we still have a long
way to go to improve upon that but
i think the advances are quite
real and tangible and i think the next
few decades will bring many more and and
i think the next few years will actually
help us refine what we do have
yeah that's definitely encouraging and
appreciate you putting that perspective
and giving that perspective for our
listeners as well
as you were giving you giving you the
floors over the closing the closing
words oh gosh no pressure yeah no i
think um conversations like this or your
podcast you know i've listened to almost
every episode at this point those those
give
those things give me hope i think
you know um
we are having a more public dialogue
than ever about these things
and
are making
some significant strides
in our awareness how we think about
things how we talk about things
you know i think the pandemic is
definitely pushing our health care
system actually as i think just push it
way past the brink and i think we're
going to be forced
to
reconsider this system that we've built
and i'm hoping that
you know i think we're going to see a
large
mental health kind of fallout from this
if we're not already seeing it and and
what we build and imagine in the future
we'll have to consider that whether we
choose to or not it's going to be in our
faces
so in some ways you know i feel hopeful
about that i also think
you know nationally and internationally
um you know along with the pandemic
there's you know
i think more awareness of racism and
oppression and
um these kind of things are challenging
us to figure out
how do we cause harm
how do we help
and how do we show up for each other in
a way that i think is a really different
at least for me personally is also just
it's very has a very different quality
and a very different conversation and i
think as we learn to show up for each
other
better
i think both we can reduce depression
from it happening to begin with but then
also you know have have more resources
and supports
to get people help
um so yeah that's where i'm at really
well said when you put that i mean put
that in great context too
again this you know we touched it
touched the tip of the uh the iceberg
but we also covered a lot and i think i
mean just a level of honesty and sincere
that you both share too i know it's
going to be really important for a lot
of a lot of folks and also be curious
about questions people have on this
episode too so i mean at some point
we'll have to have a round two and
continue the conversation but definitely
appreciate both of you being here
hope you both have a good uh
good holiday i know that can be
challenging as well but some time to
relax and just grateful again for
where you all went and just the uh
the investment that you're both making
in so many different ways so thanks so
much for joining the idr podcast i
appreciate both of you
yeah thanks so much for having me i
would love to come back if you have us
okay excellent it was really my pleasure
me and
great seeing you again ashley
great to see both of you
[Music]
you